- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Hello, everybody.
My name is [? Rado, ?] and I'm
on the Angular team in Google.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- [SPEAKING CHINESE].
Sorry, I'll have
to speak English.
My Chinese is still
not that good.
So what I'm here to talk
about a little bit more
is our collaboration between
Angular and TypeScript.
So we saw how great
TypeScript is.
Let's talk a little bit
about Angular and TypeScript.
So you might be wondering, we
work for different companies,
Microsoft and Google,
Angular and TypeScript,
how did this
collaboration come to be?
How did we started
working together?
So this story
begins around 2014.
Angular 1 was very
popular at the time.
But we're looking at where
the web is going, where
all these great
features like ES6,
the new standards for
JavaScript, the evergreen
browsers, we knew that we need
to put Angular 1 on the side
and build the next best
environment for building
web applications.
And right from the
beginning, we knew
that part of that environment
has to be some tooling.
Javascript, just like
[INAUDIBLE] said,
is not good enough for building
large scale web applications.
We need some tooling.
And we tried to invent
our own for a little bit.
We tried to build
something called AtScript.
We announced it in 2014.
And quickly afterwards, we
got in touch with TypeScript
and realized why build
the same tool twice.
Why not join efforts, use
TypeScript in Angular,
and bring you guys the best
environment for building
applications for the future?
And ever since the end of 2014,
we've been working together.
And here's a list of
features that we implemented
through great collaboration.
A lot of design discussions have
happened between the two teams.
And we think this is a great
environment that you guys can
use nowadays, Angular
2 with TypeScript.
So yeah, here we are on stage.
Great love for each other.
Our teams are-- it's a nice
story, Google and Microsoft
sharing hugs.
All right, so I want to
show you a little demo now.
We're all excited
about Angular 2.
We saw lots of demos
I know a lot of you guys still
have Angular 1 applications
out there.
So I want to show
you how easy it
is to take an Angular
1 application written
in Javascript-- there was no
TypeScript around when Angular
1 was popular, and I'll
take a demo from Angular 1
and migrate it
incrementally to TypeScript.
All right, so here's
our application.
It is purely JavaScript.
There's nowhere
TypeScript to be seen.
I have the application
running, and it's
one of our earliest
demos, actually.
Some of you might recognize
it from five years ago,
two years ago.
It's application that shows you
your favorite mobile devices.
And it's really showing
its age, both in code
and in the images you see.
Those are some
really old phones.
But we have to live
with such applications.
Sometimes we have
to maintain them.
So let's see.
What can we do to make
this a little bit better.
So first thing I'll do
is TypeScript compiler
has this flag TSC in it.
What this does is creates
a configuration file
in my project for the
TypeScript compiler.
Next thing I'll do is
I will allow JavaScript
in my TypeScript project.
Just like [INAUDIBLE] said,
JavaScript is valid TypeScript.
I will take all my JavaScript
files, rename them to source,
add them to my
include path, and tell
TypeScript to compile
to the directory
where the files used to be.
OK.
With that in place, I can
start a TypeScript compiler.
And, compilation
complete-- so it
looks like it didn't do much.
I just fed all the JavaScript
files through TypeScript,
and they ended up
where they used to be.
But now I have TypeScript
in my toolchain.
So now I can continue and
take one of these files,
these components here,
rename it to TypeScript,
and now I can start
writing TypeScript.
So first thing I see--
an error about Angular.
TypeScript is reminding me,
you are using window.error.
You never told me that
this is safe to do, right?
If you forgot your
script tag, you
might have not had Angular
on the window object.
So this is a valid
mistake, valid warning,
but I can, for now,
just tell TypeScript
don't worry about it.
It is there.
And hit Continue.
So the next thing I'll do is--
OK, this is the JavaScript
you used to write.
I think all of us have
written JavaScript.
There's this famous
problem with JavaScript.
This is not lexically bound.
I think all of us have been
burned by this at some point.
The TypeScript
has moved forward.
ES6 has a nice
solution for this,
which is the fat arrow function
has this being syntactically
bound, lexically bound.
And I can right away
start using this.
So right here, this
function, which
was problematic in the past,
and I had to do this workaround,
now I just write a very
short arrow function,
and it would work as intended.
So I made my code clearer
and easier to read.
It's still not that
great though, right?
If you look at the
levels of indentation,
this is 4 levels in.
What if I can use some other
constructs, like a class?
A lot of other
languages have this,
and JavaScript now has it.
So really what I have here
is a clause declaration.
So I can just move
this constructor.
All rights.
And next this is
this function here.
This is just a method.
It was a very verbose
way of saying that,
whereas now it's a
lot more readable,
and I can take all of
this and pass that down
as the Controller.
OK, so one last thing.
TypeScript tells me
there are two errors.
They're not really errors.
It's just that we never
told TypeScript what are
the valid fields on this class.
So I need to declare
phone is any for now,
and main image URL is a string.
OK, and now, very quickly, I'll
just reformat this cleanly,
and now we can all
agree, I think,
that this reads a lot better
than what we had originally.
This is more maintainable,
more readable,
and we can use it
in our application.
Moreover, TypeScript
will help me catch bugs.
So imagine I mistyped image.
Right away, I get the error.
I don't need to save this.
Open the browser, see that
the image is not there.
Try to debug the
workflow that you used
to have in plain JavaScript.
All right.
And the best part is you're
saying, oh, this is all great,
but I'm using features that are
not available in the browsers
where my users are.
So I'm targeting IE6.
Remember, I was [INAUDIBLE]
TypeScript behind the scenes.
It's compiling
after every change.
And if I open, this
is the actual code
that would run in the browser.
And this is valid code
in older browsers.
So TypeScript is letting me
write with the newest features
that are available in JavaScript
while supporting the browsers
that I have to support.
And just to quickly check the
application is still there,
everything is fine.
All right.
So let's go back
to the slide deck.
So that was Angular
1 with TypeScript.
So we went from no TypeScript to
incrementally adding TypeScript
to application.
Let's talk about Angular
2 and TypeScript.
So while Angular 1 can
be used with TypeScript,
Angular 2 is great
with TypeScript.
Angular 2 was built
with TypeScript in mind
from the beginning.
And it is written in TypeScript,
and it also is used--
its ergonomics when you're
using Angular 2 with TypeScript,
it's probably the best
experience you'll get.
You can use it with ES6 and
ES5, but the ergonomics really,
really shine with TypeScript.
So I have another demo.
OK, so we've heard from
Stephen earlier today.
We saw Angular 2 in action.
We've heard that the component
is the main building block
of Angular 2 applications.
And here I have a
little application which
lets me list my favorite foods.
It has only one
component so far.
I just want to point out the
parts that we're using here
that are enabled by TypeScript.
So we're using modules to
structure our application.
This is spec'd by the
new JavaScript standards,
but it's not in any
browser right now.
TypeScript transpiles
this to the browsers
that we're using today.
We have a class down here.
This is what controls my
application, my component, that
is also a new feature
in JavaScript.
And finally, what glues
everything together,
what tells Angular that this is
a component, is this Decorator.
And the Decorator is a
feature that TypeScript
provides that we make great
use of in the framework.
So the Decorator tells us
this is an Angular components,
and here is the template.
So what I'm going to do next
is, so far, this application
doesn't do much.
I have my favorite foods
actually stored in a service
down here, at the food
store, and Angular 2,
just like Angular 1, is built
around dependency injection.
So I will use
dependency injection
to take this food service
and put it in my component.
So here's how it
would look like.
First, I will import
it from the module.
I didn't do anything magical.
I just pressed Auto-Complete,
and, because TypeScript
knows all the symbols,
I can just hit Enter.
There's no other exported
symbols from that module.
Constructor.
So in the constructor, I
will inject the food store.
And I can start
using it right away.
So this is the magic of
dependency injection.
I just say what I need, and I
receive it and start using it.
You've done this in Angular 1.
So this might not be
a surprise to you.
What is surprising, and
I want to point out here,
is that we use the
type for the injection.
So knowing what to
inject in Angular 1,
we didn't have the
type, so we had
to rely on the argument
of the function which
it could be problematic
if you're using minifiers
and other tooling.
In Angular 2, the type is
really the natural language
of the dependency injection.
And this is an example
where TypeScript
allows us to use a feature
that makes the framework
work better.
So I have the food store.
And the code writes
itself, literally,
because [INAUDIBLE]
completion, it turns out
the foods returns a promise.
The promise has a
[INAUDIBLE] method.
And I will take the
foods and assign them
to the food variable, and save
all this, open it in a browser.
And here are my favorite foods
that I hope to eat them all
when I'm here in China.
Let's see if it will happen.
All right.
All right, so we started
building our application.
The next thing
that I want to show
is that happens very often.
Your coworker comes
over and says, hey,
I have this great component.
It's called Thumbs.
It lets you vote for
your favorite food.
You should use it
in your application.
Somebody else has
written this code.
I don't know anything about it.
Let's see how can I integrate
it into my existing component.
So I open this, and wow,
that's a lot of code.
How can I quickly
find the Angular API
this component exposes?
I just look for the
decorators, right?
Here is the component decorator.
It has a selector, tells
me how I can use it.
Vote Thumbs is
the tag that would
put this component on my page.
And the second thing is, I
want to somehow be notified
when the voting happens.
I just look for the
output to decorator.
Again, the decorators
point out exactly what
I need to look for, and I
start using this component.
So here it is.
There's a change event.
I would just bind
to onChange handler.
And I can go back to the
components I'm writing
and write this onChange handler.
OK.
So I'll pass an event.
What should be the
type of this event?
I can use any, and
open in the browser,
and try to look around.
But there's something
even better.
Turns out my co-worker that
wrote this component exposed
the interface of the event.
I just need to import
it, add it here,
and now I can start
using the event
because I have auto-completion
on the fields that
are available on this subject.
And again, if you're coming
from some other languages,
this might not be a
shocking revelation to you.
But for lots of
JavaScript developers,
this is a productivity tool
that they have been missing,
and have been developing
with, basically, subpar tools.
So what do I do?
Very quickly, I
would just, let's
say, count, total count of
votes, so I start with zero,
and every time somebody
upvotes an item, I will add up,
downvotes an item,
I will subtract.
Let's save all the files.
And let's see what
happens in my demo.
Here it is.
OK, so I can vote.
Actually, I like [INAUDIBLE].
All right, sorry.
I like them all.
What am I saying?
All right.
So that's the end of my demo.
Oops.
Let's try it again.
Here it is.
Just to reiterate, what
you saw is a number
of TypeScript features
that really play well
with the framework.
And together, we can make
use of ES6 features that
get transpiled to ES5,
so you start using
the future of JavaScript today.
We make great use of decorators
that really separates cleanly
the code that you write and the
code that the framework needs.
So we have this nice
separation of concerns.
And finally,
dependency injection
really shines when
you have types around.
We all know and love dependency
injection from Angular 1.
But with types, the code is more
readable and more maintainable.
All right, so I'll pass
it to [INAUDIBLE] again.
- OK.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Thank you.
One more announcement--
we do have
more talks about
Angular 2, except they
won't be in this room.
It's 430.
Stephen will show us how
to build a progressive web
applications.
It will be room 309.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And also, we have some
stickers right here.
Come right after the talk and
grab a sticker for TypeScript.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]